next to the wealthiest neighborhood of
Senegal's capital Dakar is the poor
fishing Village of angor the site of
what the government calls a police
operation to maintain Law and Order for
demonstrators it is a fight against what
they describe as an increasingly
repressive State they want a school the
government wants to build a police
station instead I'm hiding my face
because we are scared of what is
happening in our country no one can
express themselves freely journalists
are being locked up and also political
figures of the opposition so what do you
think would happen to us
riots are spreading after opposition
leader sanco called for a nationwide
Civil Disobedience movement heavily
armed police are being deployed
we try to enter the village but the
police will not let us in or allow us to
film threatening to arrest us residents
too are turned away unable to go to work
or go to school
we have to conduct operations to
maintain Law and Order In order to
protect the population people should be
allowed to demonstrate but people also
need to be able to go to work or school
without being stopped by demonstrations
we avoid police checkpoints with the
help of demonstrators who show us what
the security forces don't want us to
film residents say their homes were
stormed in the middle of the night while
they were sleeping scores are wounded
others arrested beaten and some killed
this is not a political protest and what
is happening is incomprehensible to us
we don't understand all we want is a
high school not a police station
president mikisal is calling for calm
and dialogue meanwhile local authorities
say security forces are shooting on
protesters using live rounds
look at the demonstrators behind me
they're mostly children boys and girls
fighting with rocks against police and
ride here because they want a school for
an education they say they have been
denied
government isn't listening to us the
president isn't listening to us no one
wants to help us so we are expressing
ourselves as we can anger is spreading
more than political unrest for young
people this is a crisis of trust they
feel ignored overlooked and silenced by
a statement to protect them
Nicholas Hawk Al Jazeera Dakar and Gore